all right i want to talk a little bit
about democratic congressman jamie
raskin jamie raskins a super interesting
guy many of you emailed me when i said
last week who are
interesting candidates on the democratic
side if joe biden were not to run for
reelection many of you wrote in about
jamie raskin and i'm going to talk about
that in a moment but the news with jamie
raskin is that in a recent interview he
says straight up
trump will be held accountable for his
crime wave there will be consequences to
donald trump
for the things that he did
there's a newsweek article about this
which we will look at guilty as sin
jamie raskin promises trump will answer
for crime wave representative jamie
raskin from maryland has labeled former
president donald trump quote guilty as
sin
while vowing that he will get his
comeuppance over the january sixth
attack on the u.s capitol raskin a
member of the house january 6 committee
described trump as a one-man crime wave
during a recent salon interview attorney
general merrick garland filed seditious
conspiracy charges against members of
the far-right oath keepers militia group
raskin noted before suggesting garland
may also choose to eventually bring
criminal charges against the former
president
people were on garland's case about the
fact that there had been no indictments
for seditious conspiracy and then there
was a huge indictment on seditious
conspiracy against the oath keepers
raskin told salons dino bidala and
presumably more to come
they obviously weren't the only group
there
there were overlap there were these
overlapping circles of conspiracy to
knock over the capital and take down our
government and the key moment
trump will get his comeuppance jamie
raskin says i know how maddening and
frustrating it is to people i share the
feeling having been an impeachment
manager he's as guilty as sin he's a
one-man crime wave and it's amazing that
his dad's money and this pack of lawyers
that he travels with have been able to
get him off everything up until
now
um i have to tell you that i of course
hope that jamie raskin is correct
i am very skeptical that jamie raskin is
correct and i don't doubt his intentions
and i don't doubt his commitment to
holding trump accountable for all or
some of the things that he did
but i am extraordinarily skeptical that
trump is going to really face
consequences beyond you know maybe not
having a viable candidacy in 2024 but
the thing i want to bring up with you
now and kind of chat about is
i like jamie raskin
um jamie raskin as a democratic
presidential candidate
is interesting to me and of course i'm
not suggesting joe biden
be primaried although i have no moral
opposition to it although i think strong
primary challenges to a sitting
president are likely to hurt that party
but
you guys know i don't care about the
democratic party in any in any serious
way i care about who are the best people
i think a lot of you guys have convinced
me that jamie raskin is someone that
should be at least thought about as a
potential presidential candidate in the
future a constitutional law professor
by trade
a
progressive activist like an actual
activist um he was an actual member of
the progressive caucus endorsed by the
bernie affiliated pac-hour revolution i
mean that this is a progressive guy by
every uh reasonable uh assessment worked
for the separation of church and state
true separation of churches state and
state worked to ban discrimination on
the basis of sexual orientation and
gender identity
did a great job during donald trump's
second impeachment trial um the i hate
to say it but
i think
one of the issues someone like jamie
raskin comes up against is
not insignificant amounts of
anti-semitism in the united states and
uh i i don't mean just on the right i've
talked before about left-wing
anti-semitism and uh think back to
the year 2000 when joe lieberman
um was al gore's vice presidential
running mate joe lieberman was the
epitome of like the uncontroversial
centrist moderate
uh you know the there was much more
concern about the fact that joe
lieberman wasn't really on the left then
there was that that he was too far on
the left
and the anti-semitism was just
completely off the charts and that was
20 years ago before it was sort of more
okay
to be openly anti-semitic as it is now
in in many cases so i do think raskin
would
come up against that but i think he's an
interesting guy
extremely well spoken i'm not going to
pretend and say he's sort of the
high energy the the the picture of like
high-energy
youth
he's not that but he's quite a bit
younger than joe biden
uh i think a better speaker
more of an actual progressive and a very
very interesting guy and of course i'm
not suggesting anything about the 2024
democratic primary the first question is
just is is joe biden going to run for
reelection i don't think we have an
answer to that yet when the white house
has asked about it they say
joe biden intends to run for re-election
ah it's pretty narrowly worded
i don't know that we can read too much
into it but uh jamie raskin promises
trump will
get his comeuppance i hope he's right i
remain skeptical
even if like me you're not vegan and
you're not vegetarian
eating a more plant-based diet is a
really great thing to do for a number of
different reasons and our sponsor just
egg is the delicious plant-based egg you
can use it anywhere you use traditional
eggs because the taste and texture are
identical but just egg plant-based eggs
have the same amount of protein as
traditional eggs i use it all the time
at home you can make fluffy scrambled
eggs you can make omelets you can make
quiche frittata crepes
fried rice you should see my fried rice
recipe you can really use it anywhere in
baking or anywhere you would use
traditional eggs when i first tried just
egg
i was surprised that a plant-based egg
could both taste and cook
just like traditional eggs you can get
it at the grocery store instacart amazon
go try it eating a more plant-based diet
is a great decision i do it and i'm not
vegan or vegetarian and just egg makes
it that much more easy and delicious